this tweet from interactive polls
breaking NASDAQ Falls to two year low on
Monday minus 1.84 s p lost 1.2 look at
this picture I mean there's some green
in there okay it's not as bad as that
that image of when Joe Biden was raising
his fists and then people put the
collapsing Market behind them all in red
as that Meme that was a good meme but
we're at a two-year low now and the
stock market is dropped below the levels
it was at before Biden became president
so I I don't want to make this one
political I want to make this one this
segment talk about the collapse of the
economy more personal for individuals
and uh ask you know ask you drew as we
are watching an academic downturn we're
seeing inflation we're seeing gas prices
now go up my question is if this
trajectory continues for whatever reason
be it the war or whatever what happens
to the average person's life you know so
you know you as somebody who runs
fortitude Ranch this Recreation and
survivalist Community you you had to
have done all the research and your
middle of the class nuclear family
economy hits what does their life look
like and how bad can it get well you
know people are calling for the
recession so there there could be losses
of jobs coming although thus far that
hasn't really happened higher prices but
the thing that's really going to hurt
people next year is food prices not just
because of normal inflation everywhere
but because of the lack of fertilizer
since they come largely from the Ukraine
and Russia and we're not getting those
and there's there's predictions of not
just higher food prices but in some
parts of the world you're going to have
famine next year because food production
is going to be way way down food prices
are going to go way up and there have
been other contributing factors a stupid
government policies trying to stop
fertilized use in some ways for
environmental reasons but we're the
world is facing a bad famine situation
next year assuming something worse
doesn't happen like put releasing a
virus this year or nuclear war or
whatever so uh
the average family somebody who I assume
the average person they don't really pay
attention you know I was thinking we
were talking about the war stuff I was
like why don't people care about care
about this more why are there so many
people that we try and talk about I
don't care about war you know what's
going on I don't even know who that is
what you can't wear is it and then I'm
sitting here you know listening to Luke
talk about the variety of things the US
is engaged in what Russia is doing and
I'm thinking to myself this is the kind
of stuff that if you don't know about
one day it smacks you in the face that
the war erupts the food shortages the
food prices for the people that have
been paying attention and have done some
degree of preparation
they're in a much better position so
with that with that in mind let's say
this escalates to hyperinflation let's
say it does something bad happens let's
say it's either a nuclear strike let's
say it's a virus or something happens
the average person in the United States
what do you think their day is like when
the grid gets hit or when when when gas
price gases are gone or what happens in
the worst case scenario well it's bad
news for them I mean government's top
priority is protecting government and
that's that's official policy it's
called continuity of government and any
kind of disaster or collapse
um your police protection will go down
uh because number one the priority is to
protect the elected officials the Mayors
the governors everyone else so police
normally doing Patrols in your
neighborhood some of them will be called
back to increase protection and care for
government officials I mean you're near
Mount weather here I won't give out your
exact location but you're not far from
Mount weather I drove by there about a
month ago I can't believe all the
construction going on right
they've already got massive facilities
and they're expanding them for
government officials but there's nothing
done for civil defenses gone in the
United States and there's nothing being
done and the thing that makes me the
Madison there's not even the warnings uh
government should be issuing warnings to
people about situations like the coming
food price jump that we're going to
experience the likelihood of famine
because of the again the Russia Ukraine
situation and it just doesn't happen
there's there's not care for us it's all
about you know current issues and
winning votes and you know debates that
relative to life and death are trivial
all right my favorite city in all this
New York City what happens when the when
the grid gets hit when the food stops
flowing uh it'll be it'll be there used
to be a saying in the preparedness
industry you know 48 hours to animal you
know in 48 hours it takes 40 hours for
people to realize how bad it's getting
and then they turn into their animal
instincts and they would kill to survive
I think it's more today probably more
like 48 seconds or 48 minutes to animal
because people are aware now that when
the grid goes down for example again you
ought to watch grid down power-up
documentary when the grid goes down
immediately there is no water system
flowing so people are going to start
filling their bathtubs everyone does
that so within five minutes Waters
Municipal Water is gone there's no value
if everyone starts filling your bathtub
and there's no pumping going on the
system shut down so there's three days
suits applying an average Supermarket
that'll be gone in the first hour too
people are going to run to the grocery
store they're either going to pay or
more likely to just start looting people
and I think violence will start in the
first hours people stealing and
potentially killing to survive because
they're going to figure out hey there's
no way you can survive in New York City
without an electric system all right
there's a bad pandemic I disagree uh we
we were there like you were Luke you
were there during Sandy right yeah yeah
the power was gone for like two weeks in
in like like Lower East Side I think I
think it was a couple days out in the
upper west side where all the rich
people were is that what it was Luke was
like 72 hours something yeah uh Staten
Island got hit really hard
um and parts of lower Manhattan got
flooded as well as some parts of
Brooklyn and it wasn't you know it
wasn't Calamity wasn't too crazy but but
Staten Island the dudes the boat was on
the street it was nuts the issue was
that uh they could still bring food in
there was still gas there were still
cars that's localized I'm talking about
you know a national loss of the Electric
System and National you know pandemic
that's all over the place so this is
what what I mean to say is when people
have faith the government exists Aid is
coming they're chill but if something
happens where people their confidence
has to be rocked so my view is I don't
know about the first hour I think a lot
of people the smart people maybe not
even necessarily smart but the more
Cutthroat they're gonna go out and
they're going to get whatever they can
as fast as they can I think most people
in New York are going to be looking
around confused and just shrug I got to
tell you man I love telling that story
of when I worked for Fusion and the fire
alarm went off and everybody just sat
around staring at it as soon as I went I
got up and left the building and then
the people only left the building when
the fire department actually ran in with
their gear that's the average person
the Grid's gonna go down they're going
oh the power is out I gotta tell you
this a second story I was in a uh
working for fusion and I'm in New York
and the power goes out and the alarms go
on saying everyone remain calm and
remain in the building and I was like no
thanks and I left I'm like it was uh
apparently there was a flood there was
there was a leak that hit something
electrical and created a huge risk of
fire but they were like no no everyone
stay calm just just keep doing your
thing I'm not sticking around for that I
think what's going to happen in cities
like New York
something bad's really going to happen
and the average person doesn't read the
news doesn't watch the news doesn't pay
attention and if they do it's it's
through really bad sources who are lying
to them and so they're going to sit
there and they're gonna be told hey
everybody the economy is going to be
fine just stay home for the day
a day goes by the food's gone the
water's gone the economy's gone their
money's worthless these people are going
to lose it they're either I mean mostly
people are probably going to get the
maraud is going to come for them these
people don't seem the kind of people who
are going to be able to survive but some
of these guys are going to just go
around and become Marauders poor NPCs I
don't know there's a lot of obese people
in the United States I think they have a
lot of extra fat that they're going to
of course depend on and uh I'll think
they're probably going to TiVo American
Gladiators or some sports balls and and
then let their fat little you know
little way and start some fasting that
that's not by their choice but but
obviously it all depends on there's a
number of scenarios happening I I wanted
to ask you drew from from all your work
especially with intelligence what do you
think is the most likely scenario and
situation especially after coming out of
covid that that could lead to the worst
case scenario what do you think is the
most impactful the most likely situation
well at fortitude Ranch we actually
track 50 we call them trigger events
that could lead to a collapse and the
ones that we rate is you know ignoring
Ukraine right now in the current
situation but overall we rank a pandemic
a really bad pandemic is the most likely
uh event that's going to happen and you
know we've had biologists warning us so
we're actually overdue for a really bad
pandemic they tend to the the influenza
ones tend to come in Cycles we're kind
of overdue for that and it's so easy to
do man-made and it's so likely that a
country like North Korea or Iran you
know where the great Saint to Iran and
again you know will the virus spread
back to the country releases it yes but
before I release the virus I can develop
vaccines and Destiny so it won't hurt me
when it come back or it won't hurt the
people I care about in my country if I'm
Iran or North Korea I disagree and I'll
tell you why here's what I think what
happened be it Iran Russia North Korea
China or anybody Corporation they will
release the virus in their own country
first but a weaker strain of it it will
it will have a low mortality which will
result in some death but most of the
people will just get sick and then get
over it stop giving them ideas it's not
giving an idea this is what happened
with uh Spanish Flu China many people uh
I was reading about the history like why
didn't China get hit by this in fact
they did before everyone else did right
a weaker a weaker strain but a similar
strain swept across China many of them
got very very sick when the Spanish Flu
that emerges I think it was in like it
was in the United States but then it was
seen in Europe during with all the
fighting so that's how ability how it
got its name when this starts spreading
it does make its way back to China but
they already had immunity to it from the
weaker virus that had hit them so I
think what would actually happen is a
smart country produces two versions a
very weak version and a very strong
version they give themselves the weak
version first then the strong version is
released so when it does come and hit
them mortality is minimal but the point
is this technology this ability has
never existed before in human history
it's out there now there's all kinds of
forms that could happen with and you
know the experts use the word inevitable
we are going to have these kinds of
pandemics but back to your question Luke
it's not just pandemics the other really
big one likely one is our fragile
Electric System because it's vulnerable
in so many ways we've been talking about
you know a nuclear EMP attack and North
Korea's nuclear weapons this is open
source this is some classified
information the Russians help them
actually as Soviets before Russia help
them design uh nuclear weapons that are
designed for maximum EMP effect they
don't have to be accurate they go off in
our atmosphere one or two and the U.S
electric grid is toast at that point
there's Cyber attack that could take
down the grit there's physical attacks
and they've been done there was an
attack out at a station in California a
very well carried out attack that
destroyed the Transformers there Cyber
attack uh no physical attack there's a
lot of solar flares natural effects can
take down our electric grid that's again
you've got to watch this documentary
grid down power up there's so many ways
our fragile Electric System could go and
when I say go it's gone for over a year
or more and most Americans will not be
alive when if it comes back up we'll be
dead I think we've been hit by cyber
attacks but we haven't recently and you
just don't hear about it a lot of there
was a there was one story it was highly
speculative I know I know I'm just
saying just a thought it was around the
time that Donald Trump was an airstrike
was on its way to Iran Trump calls it
off and says no publicly he says I did
not think that you know 500 people who
would have died the loss of life was was
worth what we would be retaliating for
something that effect however around the
same time that the U.S launches this
this this Fleet to go conduct an
airstrike a refinery in Philadelphia
explodes
I asked some of my uh my hacker buddies
do you think there's a that what what is
the what is the likelihood that in
response to the US engaging in a
military operation Iran
used it conducted a Cyber attack against
a Refinery blowing it up and we know
they did it so we backed off they told
me it was very very low not very likely
um however possible but just not at all
likely they they all basically said no
no no no no way no way no way lottery
tickets chance but possible sure I guess
so my thing is that was just one example
of a scenario where I see this and I'm
like could it have been at the Cyber
attack blew up the uh the petroleum
Refinery so then Trump's seeing that
vulnerability cancels the attack knowing
it's going to lead to a greater
escalation in cyber warfare maybe maybe
not again I'll stress my expert buddy
said they don't think that was the case
based on how it went down but thinking
about that there have been many
circumstances where we've seen various
industrial facilities get you know have
fires start abruptly and the answer is
sometimes fire start are we hyper
focused on this and now we're assuming
it's going to be a Cyber attack or are
we in a normalcy bias that we cannot see
that we are actually under attack when
we are how would we even know
and then there's there's a lot more
threats to um the the threat of
nanotechnology some new technologies we
keep coming out with you know you were
talking earlier about unintended
consequences a lot of people working
with nanotechnology are concerned about
that Elon Musk is always talking about
artificial intelligence and and I think
the artificial intelligence threat is
very much there but not in the normal
way you see in a movie where the
computer becomes you know thinking and
evil the bigger threat from artificial
intelligence is some terrorist group or
a nation you know North Korea has
tremendous cyber capability actually
programming and releasing a virus you
know instructing computers maximize
human death through the means you've got
that kind of a system of doing it but
there's many other sources that that
could lead to disaster Beyond pandemics
or vulnerable Electric System zombies
are there new technologies
what's the over under on zombies and
civil war Civil War is a big one and so
it's just going to mention one Another
Thing Ray dalio is you know either it's
either not seem Talib or Ray Dali or
probably the two smartest people alive I
know of today he's the founder of
Bridgewater the most successful hedge
fund in history yeah we got to get Ray
Daley on the show he'll be amazing on
the show so he has estimated recently
there's a 30 percent likelihood of war
with China in the near future that's his
estimate he's a China expert and he's
also said he sees the 30 chance of civil
war after the next presidential election
he says you know the these are not
calculated numbers back to your earlier
question these are guesstimates but he's
a very wise man a hedge fund you know
his makes a success based on trying to
understand how the world is how things
are developing so again on trigger
events 30 percent chance of a war with
China that could be a nuclear war with
nuclear strikes on the Homeland that
leads to a collapse because our society
is so fragile so government dependent
and there's just a lot of bad people and
one other thing that I've never seen
this anywhere in print or in the media
but a huge threat and vulnerability we
Face the United States is the 1.5
million Americans in jail one and a half
million Americans in jail so when
there's a pandemic a 60 lethal pandemic
do you think guards are going to go to
work and risk they're not going to go to
work if the electric grid goes down how
do prisons work I used to be a county
commissioner I've been in jails jails
cannot function without electricity
that's how you control all the doors
it's all electric well they open or they
stay locked they're probably going to
come open I mean there's generator
backup hospitals will claim oh we've got
generator backup they've got back up for
maybe three days at the most that's a
good thing so you can have one and a
half million Americans most of them
aren't bad criminals but a lot of them
are who are in jail and they have
absolutely no preparedness they've got
no house they've got no food so when
they get out of their jails either
released or they just get out on their
own what are they going to do they're
going to maraud it's the only way
they're going to stay alive they don't
don't have a house they don't have home
and food and water they've got to go out
and steal from other people probably
kill them in the process to survive well
I kind of talks about that I got to say
our government is not getting us
prepared well for events that experts
are say are inevitable I I disagree on
the present thing though prisons would
be one of the safest and most secure
places to remain so if if you're there
you've got a bunch of guys you've
already got gangs so if if there's no
more guards there might be a lot of
infighting if that is the case the end
result is going to be someone who owns a
fortress now they may go in Murad but
they're going to use the prison as like
a fortress base of operations and
control it and there's weapons in there
so they are instantly going to be armed
armored and determined and have
facilities and it's it's going to be
night it's it's look I'll say it's worse
than you're you're predicting prisoners
will get out and go Murad they're gonna
have a fortress base of operations with
weapons and then you know they're gonna
go out and go on their patrols and you
probably I mean maybe you'll notice
they're wearing prison clothes but it's
not going to matter guys with guns are
going to come up and say you work for us
now we control this massive
fortification so you can't even get to
us if you wanted to thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there